Disney has made toys movies and games
that keep us all young at heart but even
they can miss the mark
sometimes we found some pretty
inappropriate toy fails that Disney
definitely shouldn't have made we still
can't believe the last one check these
out new here subscribe to the things
channel to stay up to date on our latest
videos and give us a big thumbs up if
you like this video now here are the 15
most inappropriate Disney toys ever made
inappropriate Tarzan
you know how Tarzan beats on that chest
and Bella's at that Tarzan yell that the
whole jungle can hear with all of the
technology of today it should be pretty
easy to make a Tarzan toy that beats out
of his chest and does the Tarzan yell
right well apparently not
Disney came up with a toy called the rad
repeating Tarzan and it's not the most
appropriate tour in the world the doll
does a Tarzan yell and he definitely
beats something but it's only with one
hand and it looks very similar to
another wild activity geez Tarzan can't
you find a hut or a cave to do that in
children are watching you would think
that this is the only inappropriate
Tarzan doll we found if you thought that
well you would be wrong
but let's put a pin in that for now sit
on the princesses what when we saw this
Disney kids item we couldn't help but to
rethink the lyrics to Belle's opening
number after seeing this seat we thought
the song could say there must be so much
more to this provincial place now why
don't you come and sit on my never mind
that's way inappropriate much like this
Disney Princess wishes and dreams soft
potty seat it's a hilarious potty
training device after the kids sing with
their favorite Disney Princesses they
can drop a deuce while sitting on their
faces now Ariel was really going to be
part of your world a kids actually it
looks like Ariel is not on this seat
it's only Belle Aurora and Cinderella
who had the distinct honor of witnessing
all your bathroom activity up close and
personal haven't those ladies been
through enough already cut these girls
some slack
what is
feekiee doing to Simba in the Lion King
Rafiki is a trusted friend to Simba he
helps Simba defeat scar and claim his
rightful place as the king of Pride Rock
and we all remember that classic opening
seeing where Rafiki holds baby Simba up
before the Kingdom where all the animals
are joyous and bow while the song circle
of life plays that was a great scene no
toy could ever mess up that moment right
oh boy we were wrong here is a Disney
toy that has Simba in a very
compromising position and it appears
that Rafiki is asking if you can feel
the love tonight if you watch the motion
of the toy you'll be astonished that
this thing ever made it into the world
seriously what were they thinking this
makes us see Rafiki in a whole different
light yikes Minnie Mouse cleaning set
you know how older Disney movies to pick
girls cleaning a lot in the days of Snow
White and Cinderella it seems that
cleaning and singing were all Disney
Princesses know how to do but with girl
power films like mulana brave and Mulan
it seemed like Disney turned a corner
and empowered girls to be their own
heroes and go on their own adventures
and then they made this toy introducing
the Minnie Mouse cleaning set now you
can forget all that archery voyaging on
the sea and fighting for your country
because there's dust on the windowsill
this toy is clearly geared towards girls
it's branded with Minnie Mouse and
there's a little girl on the Box we
tried to find a Mickey Mouse cleaning
set but all we could find was this tool
set way to pigeon-holed both genders
Disney The Little Mermaid original home
video cover the popcorn popping the
snuggly blankets are ready and you're
just about to put on your favorite
Disney movie but when you grab the
Little Mermaid full movie you notice
something odd on the cover this is the
g-rated Disney film and not a horrible
mistake from the wrong side of the video
store right this was the experience of
startled Disney fans when they got this
version of The Little Mermaid home video
if you look at the picture on the cover
it seems King Triton's Castle has
something a bit extra to offer did the
illustrator just fall onto the drawing
with his pants down
leave it to a dude to think what lies
between his legs should be gold
sparkling and strong enough to hold up a
castle subconscious Envy problem much
paging dr. Freud wreck-it Ralph
underwear
we love wreckit-ralph who doesn't but
some merchandising can go a little bit
too far we love the part of the movie
where Ralph is about to smash up the
building in the video game and he owes
his catchphrase I'm gonna rock that
catchphrase on its own is tame and
pretty much appropriate on any toy but
we found one place where it is
definitely not appropriate introducing
kids underwear with Ralph's bursting
through a brick wall on one side in the
phrase I'm gonna wreck it on the other
we're not underwear experts but we're
pretty sure kids underwear shouldn't
make that statement we can think of two
reasons off the top of our heads and
both of them are things we shouldn't say
just notice me seriously no
inappropriate Tigger the wonderful
things about Pinkett it figure the
wonderful things that bouncy googly
happy and cuddly what's not to love you
might be asking yourself what anyone
could possibly make Tigger inappropriate
for children well we've got your answer
introducing the Tigger doll Oh put that
thing away Tigger we know it's supposed
to be his tail but the placement is not
okay and there's a little flower on the
tip to soften the proverbial blow no pun
intended
seriously guys mine's out of the gutters
this is a doll for children we're hoping
this is a fluke packaging mistake and
not that all the Tiggers are displayed
like this
Tigger seems to be quite fond of his
tail let's just hope he doesn't bounce
on that thing this is so inappropriate
but we're laughing out loud Mickey Mouse
microphone so what was happening in the
toy makers room when they decided to
make a phallic toy that encourages kids
to put their mouths on it that's what we
wanted to know when we saw this Mickey
Mouse microphone
maybe these toy designers should have
been studying in anatomy class what
parent would want their kid to play with
this toy imagine all the interesting
songs that could be sung on this
microphone like tuba snake boogie my red
joystick or don't touch my willy yes
folks these are all real song titles
we're starting to get the impression
that there are too many
men designing Disney toys and these men
can't stop thinking about their junk for
long enough to make a toy we promised
you Disney toy makers there is more to
life and here's Tarzan again remember
when we told you to put a pin any
inappropriate Tarzan doll fun well it's
time to pull out that pin because we
just found a hilarious Tarzan toy fail
this one's hysterically inappropriate
it's just called a vine jammin Tarzan
are these toy makers just a bunch of
teenage boys look at that vine he's
holding or is that a snake regardless it
starts where it shouldn't and it coils
up before he tamed that loincloth snake
with his tight gripping fists this is
just too easy to make fun of and don't
even get us started on the name they
came up with vine jam and Tarzan could
you be any less obvious put your vine
away Tarzan you shouldn't be jamming
that thing anywhere someone sure is
obsessed with a certain part of their
Anatomy over at Disney
Olaf guts for kids if you're looking for
an easy way to totally traumatize your
kids with a sweet treat on a hot summer
day look no further introducing Olaf's
no guts if your kids love the idea of
disemboweling their favorite Disney
character diz name as gotcha Covered
with this fun summer toy Olaf will
commit hari-kari before your very eyes
you can enjoy his tasty insides while
the light leaves his eyes but the smile
on his face remains seppuku snowcone
anyone these snow cones will satisfy
your child's sweet tooth as well as his
appetite for snowman carnage he can look
into his victims eyes and laugh as he
savors every morsel of Olaf's tender and
trails for real why couldn't the snow
just come out of a cup that Olaf is
holding that is sick people stop
torturing the poor snowman what is going
on with this Donald Duck ride we want to
know what genius decided to MacDonald
Ducks beak aim straight for the writers
crotch this ride would have been totally
appropriate if they had just flipped to
the bird okay flip to the duck around so
kids could ride on his back what were
they thinking sure kids are too young to
understand what is implied here
still do we really want kids to think
that anyone's face should be down there
even if they aren't facing Donald Duck
on the ride that would still make him a
total butt sniffer no one wants to see
their favorite duck sniffing butts
seriously no one we can't even imagine
how the ride is supposed to move once
it's turned on it can only get worse
right get your beak out of here Donald
this ride is not okay Winnie the Pooh
Winnie the Pooh is a sweet fun-loving
bear who lives in the Hundred Acre Wood
and loves honey but apparently who has
an odd request he wants kids to put
rings on his crotch tower pelvic pointer
no really guys let's not try to make fun
of poor Winnie the Pooh maybe it's the
morning and he just woke up you know
about morning Hundred Acre Wood right
he's probably having a major honey dream
it's not his fault and he is just as
embarrassed as you are now somebody get
that bear a notebook so he can hide that
thing we're just praying that all the
rings that go on this toy are not pink
how are we gonna get this image out of
our heads by moving on to the next
wildly inappropriate totally of course
Buzz Lightyear to the rescue Buzz
Lightyear has got an intergalactic
mission just for you you can tell he's
really excited about this mission by the
way his straw is pointing up to infinity
and beyond and they expect kids to suck
out of that straw oh come on that's an
image we do not want to see and look at
how confident buzz is about it all he's
just standing there straw sticking out
in the wind with his arms crossed and
that smug look on his face he is very
proud of that disproportionately sized
straw isn't he he thinks it's very
impressive as if this guy needs another
reason to be full of himself
put it away buzz save it for your straw
fight with Emperor Zurg we're willing to
bet that he probably thinks his straw is
the biggest one in the galaxy anyway
frozen bikini Disney's frozen is
probably the biggest toy and clothing
franchise of all time you can't go to
any department store without seeing Elsa
Anna and Olaf on toys clothes and
accessories but why stop with winter
attire they really thought of everything
when they designed this bikini about an
ice princess who curses the kingdom to
endure an eternal winter pool
party here is the frozen print bikini
bottom perfect for the Summer Sun which
would melt sweet little Olaf without the
little snow Elsa cloud put over his head
now if you look closely you'll see how
this bikini is really inappropriate is
that a flower in the middle with an
upside-down v-shaped window leading up
to it again that Disney merchandise
designers might want to take an anatomy
class so they would know what to avoid
Hannah Montana what have you done now we
all know how controversial Miley Cyrus
can be but who knew her days of
controversy began during her Hannah
Montana days Disney thought would be a
fantastic idea to sell young fans this
concert candy their sweet and sour
candies which the packet says are all
individually wrapped for portion control
cuz you don't want your daughter
guzzling down too many of these okay
real talk who in the world thought it
would be a good idea to make these
gummies flesh-toned if that's what the
guitar-shaped ones look like we shudder
to imagine what the microphone ones look
like you got us good Miley we can't
believe they actually put these on the
market these inappropriate toys Hannah's
laughing out loud do you have a favorite
inappropriate Disney toy do you know of
any ones that we missed tell us about it
in the comment section below and that's
all for the 15 most inappropriate Disney
toys ever made thanks for watching the
things bye
[Music]